para aprender el secreto de cómo movían estas inmensas piedras.
Y resulta que los cíclopes ni siquiera son tan fuertes.
Aunque sí son muy inteligentes
y se las idearon para que el material trabajara para ellos.
Estas criaturas enormes de piedra y tambaleantes que ven a mis espaldas
son el resultado de esa colaboración.
Pues bien, los cíclopes podrán ser criaturas míticas,
pero esas maravillas existen hasta el día de hoy.
Las personas las crearon.
Pero también crearon mitos sobre ellas.
Y, en lo que refiere a las maravillas, existe un tejido conectivo
que une la mitología con la realidad.
Consideren la isla de Pascua.
Cuando los exploradores holandeses llegaron por primera vez a la isla,
preguntaron a la gente de Rapa Nui
cómo habrían podido sus ancestros mover semejantes estatuas.
Y los rapanui contestaron:
"Nuestros ancestros no movieron las estatuas,
porque las estatuas mismas caminaban".
Durante siglos, se desestimó semejante explicación, pero es verdad.
Las estatuas, conocidas como "moái", fueron trasladadas a pie,
haciendo que se movieran de lado a lado.
¿Sí?
Y si bien los moái fascinan a los visitantes en la actualidad,
imaginen haber estado allí
cuando estos moái colosales iban marchando por la isla.
Porque el verdadero monumento no son los objetos mismos,
sino el rito cultural de conferir vida a las piedras.
Como arquitecto, persigo también ese sueño.
¿Cómo podemos cambiar nuestra idea de la construcción
para contemplar ese aspecto mítico?
Me he estado planteando desafíos
y he puesto en escena una serie de presentaciones
sobre la tarea antigua aunque bastante sencilla
de mover y poner de pie objetos enormes y pesados,
como este megalito de casi 5 m de altura
diseñado para caminar y mantenerse erguido;
o este gigante de casi 2 toneladas
que se incorpora y cobra vida para bailar en el escenario.
Y he descubierto que al concebir la arquitectura
no como un producto final sino como una interpretación,
desde la idea misma hasta su concreción,
redescubrimos algunas formas verdaderamente ingeniosas de construcción.
La mayor parte del debate sobre el futuro
se centra en la tecnología, la eficacia y la velocidad.
Pero si hemos aprendido algo de los cíclopes,
es que las maravillas pueden ser inteligentes, espectaculares
y sustentables,
tanto por su masa como por su misterio.
Si bien la gente aún quiere saber
cómo se crearon las maravillas de la Antigüedad,
yo he estado consultando a los cíclopes sobre cómo crear el misterio
que motiva a las personas a hacer justamente esa pregunta.
Ya que en una era en la que diseñamos edificios
para que duren 30 o 60 años,
a mí me encantaría aprender a crear obras que entretengan durante toda la eternidad.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)